[Müzik]
yeni
evlenme birçoğumuz bu kavramları
duyuyor Ama derin
lemesine ve bunların hepsini yapay
zekadan düşüklüğüne de bilmiyoruz
işte bugün
yapay ilk öncelikle Yapay Zeka
ve nasıl bağlamada gelmiş
bulunalım ilk Yapay Zeka
1900 çok ciddi yapmamıştım Çünkü daha o
zaman evli olan bir yapay zekâ
lı
ıb'nin
En iyi satranç oyuncusu
[Müzik]
beğenmişti bu Diplo dediğimiz Makina
ama yapay
hikayesi kendi bilgi dolanımı
sayesinde amelleri öngörebiliyor
Burada da Gördüğünüz üzere
Peki as
ıl Yapay Zeka hayatımızı daha farklı
daha fazla dahil etmeliyiz bunun Aslında
belli başlı sebepleri var Bunlardan ilki
Bizlere çok önemli faydalar sağl
asın Bunlardan ilki hızlı olması ve
zamanda zarfı sağlanması Gördüğünüz
üzere
kendiniz Bir kütüphaneye gidin herhangi
bir bilgi edinmeye kalsanız bir kitaba
hakim ettiniz ve bunun için saatlerinizi
alacaksınız
bunu yapmak çok fazla
ancak Google'a girdiğiniz zaman Bir
saniyenin altında
bir yıllarca sonuç elde edebiliyoruz ve
bu da
zaman tasarrufu
bunların makineler sayesinde
her
şey kendi özel
olduğunu diğer bir yandan daha doğru ve
daha net sonuçlar vermesi yapay zekanın
hayatımıza katılmasının bir nedenidir
bunu sizlere şöyle örnek
lendirelim hepimiz
problemler de gerek denklemlerde bunları
kullanırız Hepimiz bir hata yaparız ve
bu hata sonucunda bazen bir mühendisi
bir binaya Yanlış olan
bazen sınavlarımızda bir soru kaybederiz
ve benzeri sonuçları yolacağım ama Hesap
makineleri
onlar da
diyemez bu hepimiz biliyoruz yabancı
ve diğer bir Diyardan daha net sonuçlar
vermesi bir yol görünür
derseniz
ki bir mesafe var şu kadar şu kadar
benzin yakar
üç aşağı beş yukarı kurabilirsiniz Tabii
ki farklılıkla ilgili olabilir ama yine
Yapay Zeka
harcayacağınız zaman ve harcayacağımız
benzinle bir şekilde gözlerinizi
yönlendir
ebilir ve diğer bir yandan daha az
gereksinimle aynı işi yapması bundan
kastım şu
Dur bir işe başlayacağız Örneğin
bir cisim açalım
olmanızı susuz olmamanız gerekiyor
Bulunduğunuz ortamınız sizin dikkatinizi
dağıtmaması gerekir
o gün
moraliniz iyi olmadı vesaire vesaire
gibi çok
fazla ama ya ben zeka Önemli bir şey yok
yok gerekli kopya yazarsanız
ve gerekli enerjiyi verdiğiniz takdirde
aynı işi çok daha basit bir şekilde
yapabilir
Ayrıca hatırlatıcılık yapar bundan
kastım
türü aklımıza tutmak için yıllar
filtresi bile hep bir enerji sarf ederiz
tarihin
unuturuz kiminle beraber olduğumuzu
unuturuz vesaire vesaire derken hepsi
atmamıza
ancak Yapay Zeka böyle değildir
Peki oraya bir kere koyarsınız ve
bildiğin orada durduğu sürece hiçbir
enerji harcadığını
gerekli Ayrıca saati saatine günü gün
[Müzik]
üne ve diğer bir yandan
Günümüzün en moder
n konusu bundan kastım çünkü
Gördüğünüz üzere Mete
iliyor bilgiler Kripto paralar yeni
ekonomik
düzen bunları birçoğumuz biliyoruz Sen
bak
Bunlar sayesinde insanlar yine ekonomik
uğraşların
yeni meslek
leri yine hobiler çıktı ve bu insanlar
gibi bir serpme atmış
oldum diğer bir yandan yapay zekaya
karşı bazı yanlış anlaşılmalar
ımız şunu
mutlaka ileride bizden hiçbir farkı
olmayan yaratık
Lara da biri var mı olmayacaktır
Bunlar Bana kalırsa asılsız yargılardır
ve doğru olmayacağını
söyleyeyim İyi ki sağduyulardır sağduyu
dediğimiz
şey zaten
sizin Söylemediği şeylerdir
[Müzik]
ve bağdaştırarak
bu saldırılar şöyle bir mesela
size balerin bale gibi
Kral yöneticileri kralın
bunlar
ama yap
ay zeka bir kodları
yazarak birleştirelim sonunda halled
in Ya ben sağlıyorsa
almış oluyor bunlar genelde
gördünüz
Yani bu sağlıyor
projenin en büyük
yanı bu iki fotoğraf arasında
proje başladığında
bitmedi Çünkü sağlığı
güç ve sağlamak için milyonlarca yıla
ihtiyacımız var
diğer bir yandan duygular
duygular Biz canlıları Biz insanları biz
yapan şeyler
çevremizdeki hayvanların etkilerini
insanlar hepsinin duyguları var ve
duygular sayesinde bir şeyler yapar
lar Bir de hesapla
bir ameliyat
en az riskli olan haber
verirsin ama robotlarda yani Yapay Zeka
da bu yok
onlar
her yer
vermediğimiz onların Özgür
lüğü ve empati
yapamamaları en büyük eksikliklerinden
biridir
ve yapay zekaya hayatımızı daha fazla
nasıl dahil ederiz
bireylere küçük yaştan itibaren yapay
zekanın ciddi eğitimler veriliyor Çünkü
artık üniversite hayatları gittiğinde ve
hayatlarının
çok daha donanımlı olduğuna
inandım üniversiteye
girişinde bir arka planları olmaları
lazım çünkü Eğer hiçbir şey bilmeden
sıfırdan öğrenme panterlerse burada bir
vakit diğer bir yandan Güvenlik
o güvenliği başlı
data güvenli olarak açıklayabiliriz
mesela birçoğumuzun aslında olaylarını
biliyordur bilgilerimizin çalınması ya
da işte
bilgisayarımızın ele geçir
ilmesi Bunlar Güvenlik
önlemleri Bu yüzden yapay zekaya olan
güvenen yapay zekaya güvenin
azalmasından dolayı 10 insanlar tercih
et
memeye Bizim amacımız onu
hayatta dahil Olam
ve diğer bir yanda yazılımcılara
girişimciler günümüz Evet
ilerleyişi Ama eğer
bir dille Sağ
lanmazsa revaç düz
eyine
[Alkış]